and that was the beginning of wide area
gaming that's good because we would play
games like trade wars now do you
remember something called fido net i do
not but you got it right so the way that
like the different bbs's would
communicate back then we had long
distance uh telephone charges right
right like you got in the phone if you
called outside your local area you were
paying by the minute get off the phone
you're running up the phone right
but in your local area you could you
know call unlimited yes right and so you
can get on you'll stay on the bbs all
night
but there was no if you wanted to talk
somebody in california you know calling
california was just prohibitively
expensive
so fido net was a network where the bdss
could communicate and transfer files
from one to another with these
overlapping local calling areas wow
so they would literally like send a
message from one and then it would call
the next one 30 miles down the road
which is a local call for that one send
the message call the next one 30 miles
down the road so it was all local hops
right right so no one was running along
this nobody's doing a long distance yeah
yeah it's called store and forward
networking okay um so it wasn't real
time right but you could send a message
over fido net that might get across the
country in a day or two
and so within the game you know
but the games right now you're playing
games like trade wars sort of like these
science fiction star trek type uh
exploration games where you get one move
a day right everyone would send in their
moves right because you're moving your
your you know your flotillas and your
spaceships around and then the next day
you'd check in and it would have like
synced up got yourself uh let me tell
you right now that would kill this
generation
literally the fomo that they would have
the
addict would not survive play play x-com
in this generation where he do his move
and then he got logged in tomorrow to
see the next
time addict
no no but you know but at least there's
real people right right it's not real
time but now you're sort of part of
something broader yes um and i never got
into uh aol or genie because i was doing
the dvs stuff right right um and they
have all kinds of different you know
shady software you can download and
whatnot um but that was uh so that was
you know important for me um went to
college uh in 1990
and
uh that's where we covered the internet
right um because back then you know
there was no graphic there was no web
right and the only way really to get on
the internet was either to work in the
military or to be at a university
situation correct where you could um so
i showed up
uh college in connecticut
uh and that my school had all these unix
mainframes and uh vms so you shout out
to college connecticut i got connecticut
peeps that's awesome i'll just if you
want to if you would no no i went to
yale okay cool
uh uh in new haven new haven yeah
but uh eunuchs hadn't even taken over
yet they still had uh deck dms
mainframes uh as well but unix was
clearly taken over
and so what you could do is they would
let you have a phone line and he could
dial in i remember literally walking up
to we call science hill okay at yale
because they you know it wasn't this new
student orientation was like yeah
there's the computer lab over there go
print your papers over there they
weren't even trying to get the kids onto
the text-based internet um and i
remember like literally walking up
science hill to go to the computer
science department just to ask them hey
like what do i need to do uh to uh to
dial in and get in on this and they're
like why do you want to know
oh
wait breaking protocol
[Laughter]
i can't
but all of a sudden now uh and i gotten
on mac at that point um i had gotten i'd
gone from commodore to mac um but you
weren't i wasn't really running games on
the machine now you're just dialing in
and it's all just uh telnet you know uh
yes tell that space but you know all the
stuff you know discovering email uh
usenet news groups um sort of the
predecessor to you know reddit or
whatever you call it um for global news
groups and i was always really into
hippie music so i was on the grateful
dead uh news group as well as the you
know the gaming ones
but you could telnet right into another
computer
and there was um
a group of games called mods um
multi-user dungeons otherwise known as
multiple undergraduate destroyers
[Laughter]
and so you know we had all grown up
playing a certain type of game called
you know text adventures right infocom
games like you know adventure zork or
you type you know go east go north you
know attack dragon whatever yeah but
some of them you know really detailed uh
and whatnot but they're all single
player right like you know offline
and you start playing these games called
muds and so you tell them that i
remember telling that into this computer
um in the texas a m university and a
game called darker realms right these
are tech space adventures and you sort
of log in you make a character it says
you know you're in a church with a sword
you get sword go south go east and to me
it just looks like a normal
single-player
uh adventure right
like oh it's bigger on another computer
and i remember i'll never forget
probably one of the most important
moments in my personal gaming history
is i just started you're sitting in a
tavern okay and you're just sort of like
this you know and you're sitting there
and all of a sudden it just pops up a
green elf enters the room
so what
like in real time you're seeing the
waiting it's the green elephant
and it says the green elves says hi
what what
excuse me what
and um and uh and you're like what uh
and
it says you know the green elf says like
how you doing
this had to blow your mind at the time
could you imagine you said your tavern
and the green elf walks and you're like
what uh-huh
this is it's a line of text right yeah
it's a text that's yes
and i said say you know
hi yeah yeah and and then the greenhouse
says you know like
that's a real that's a real person yes
[Music]
that was like mind blown like there was
a real person like hey are you doing are
you a new player like yes i'm a new
player like hey do you want to go like i
was like wait like what what and they're
like and they're saying all right let's
go kill you know the orc down the road
i'm like okay it's like you know he said
go east and i'll be there and it says
the green elf leaves the room
yes
so long story short my undergraduate
career was not quite destroyed
get some work done
super deep on you know these mmos i'm
sorry they weren't called mm-hmm they
were
they were called mods
tech space but here's the thing right it
was all about the community yes of
people and there's two aspects i want to
highlight number one was the way these
games were set up um was that once you
got to like max level yeah you became
what's called a wizard and once you're a
wizard you could create new areas in the
game yourself oh wow
once you've reached max level it would
literally unlock a scripting language
where you could start to create new
areas in the game
so in in my game darker realms there was
like a star trek themed area and a star
wars area in a doctor who area in a lord
of the rings area
and an edgar allen poe area that had
been coded by different players so the
game itself is constantly growing you
know it's almost like a roblox situation
yeah
type situation the creative tools here
impressive other side it was just as
important once again is about the
community right
you've got people from all over the
country who are now playing you know
largely from academia who are playing
these multiplayer games but like you
know there was no graphics on the
internet there was no way to send a
picture you know the bandwidth was so
low but people will find a way to
connect yeah right and so one of the
things i wanted to show you was the
darker realms yearbook oh wow wow
and so what people would do is literally
say hey here's an address send in
pictures of themselves
right like to a physical address where
somebody who ran the game would then put
the pictures together into a physical
wow
stories from the game and then mail back
out to the players that is so cool
and what that showed me was you know
there was no way to see if that was the
first time seeing pictures the people
you were playing with right couldn't
ever hear their voices um but people
will find a way to make community
through gaming yeah right and look and
darker realms are still running my
character is still there um they were in
a number of darker realms you know
weddings and children and whatnot but so
that's my point right is that it's all
about we talk about you know the
bringing the joy and community of gaming
to everyone on the planet you know we
all saw it you know in different ways
whether it's in the arcade whether it's
you know through a yearbook um and so
that was what really students showed me
at first at that time you know how
important the community of gaming is
that is powerful you just blew my mind
with that like
the only i i can't relate to that level
because obviously you're there
when this kind of this boom is happening
but it reminds me and saw me know this
one um remember the grail quest books
off
right and it's like yeah it would kind
of like choose your own invention but
they were like you know you create this
world and you know you turn you know do
this you create your character and it's
go here go east go left but it was it
was base it was in the structure of a
book right of a book and a and a table
top and a table top right but like what
you're saying is to me that equivalent
next level online text base with a
community like that is mind-blowing so
like you say like
game touch kojima as well
because if you think about it
he was making a game in that manner that
was the original strand game
[Laughter]
really got to think about it like
everything has a genesis point right
yeah everything has a a point of entry
right your awareness for when that elf
walked in
was mind-blowing to that extent right
and i'm pretty sure that other people
had that same experience and then when
you reach max level and you're making
these worlds you're not really crafting
these worlds for you you're giving a
piece of yourself to the world but
you're crafting the world for the other
player to walk into said world and
that's that's the expansion that's
exactly what everyone is looking for in
order to share a piece of their self uh
online to everyone else right and like
like you said you had different era star
trek i would have been in a star trek
like a star wars a star trek area and i
would have been over there all day long
but
that that is that's key because
individuals took the time out made it to
max level yes it had the same experience
that you did and decided to make a world
craft around that that is so beautiful
so seth did you make any did you make
any expansions to it or that wasn't i
never got to that level i mean because
you really had to be a real programmer
so i was just you know after the the led
zeppelin screen saver that was it yeah
i was done that was good
i did tell you that he didn't destroy
his undergrad so
you had to destroy but is that true
you would have been dropping out
it's over it's over at that point it's
over for me
as a wizard
mom i'm a wizard
i don't i don't have that support
the precursor like the way you describe
that is the way
like xbox live golden live for the first
time was for someone like me right where
it's like wait a minute i that's a real
person i'm interacting right so to me
it's like a touch point and it's just so
cool because you know
these are those inflection points in
gaming where you're like okay something
is changing
dramatically in the scope this is
mind-blowing and i really want to salute
you on that story it was powerful